a Nicolás uchet le gusta cantar
y está trabajando en su último invento
el dispositivo que estoy creando
significará que podría acoplar el
micrófono a mi mano protésica significa
que podría expresarme más fácilmente
con mi otra mano por ejemplo
Nicolás perdió su mano derecha en un
accidente laboral
tras esto decidió diseñar una gama de
dispositivos que le ayudaran a mejorar
su calidad de vida
tuve un accidente cuando trabajaba como
mecánico era lo que solía hacer usaba
mis dos manos ahora esto es una manera
de superarme y hacerlo por mí mismo
Y sí
ese es el lema de la empresa de Nicolás
que fundó para ayudar a mejorar la vida
de los discapacitados Aquí vamos ya está
mar de paz es un voluntario
eso no estoy aquí para ayudar también
trato de traer mis propias ideas pero es
una persona en situación de discapacidad
quien está a cargo de su propio proyecto
lo que creo es muy importante
matil Fox ha trabajado en su propio
proyecto por varios años
una vez por semana asiste al taller de
My human ket
[Música]
está lleno de gente apasionada
aquí todos pueden compartir sus
habilidades y aprender unos de otros
[Música]
Matilde está aquí para ajustar su
Monitor de codo
un dispositivo que ha diseñado con la
ayuda de Christian un ingeniero jubilado
estos sensores activan el dispositivo
para que pueda mover el codo y acceder a
estos botones de control
la gente que es muy débil como yo
pues muy a menudo necesita soporte la
tecnología está ahí y existe pero no
podemos pulsar el botón porque es
demasiado difícil
otras innovaciones son este joystick
fabricado a partir de un manillar de
bicicleta reciclado un dispositivo que
permite a los discapacitados utilizar
una pantalla táctil móvil
está abierto a todo el mundo sea cual
sea su formación así que todo lo que
creamos se comparte para el bien común
de la gente en internet para que pueda
reproducirse fácilmente y adaptarse a
las necesidades del mayor número de
personas posible
puede ser más autónomo simplemente con
este tornillo Y este dispositivo permite
a las personas discapacitadas reconocer
su discapacidad pero también reconocer
que tienen los mismos derechos que
cualquier otra persona sí soy una
persona discapacitada pero tengo derecho
a actos culturales deportivos musicales
como cualquier otra persona
es hora de poner a prueba el micrófono
de Nicolás
dentro de unas semanas Nicolás se
dirigirá a Japón donde quiere compartir
su creatividad e innovaciones con la
comunidad de aficionados al karaoke